[Musique]
alors l'hypnose est un état second entre
le rêve et la réalité
alors on est là mais en même temps nous
sommes dans le rêve et c'est le
subconscient qui prend le dessus sur la
conscience
[Musique]
il est celui qui a fait de l'hypnose un
véritable phénomène de mode
messmer le fascinateur québécois
multiplie les prouesses sur scène et sur
les plateaux de télévision mais
l'hypnose n'est pas seulement un
spectacle c'est un outil qui est en
train de révolutionner le monde médical
essayez d'imaginer une balance à fléau
est ce que les deux plateaux serait à la
même hauteur ou bien est ce que ça
pourrait pencher et tout en observant
les choses d'une manière neutre comme si
vous étiez une exploratrice de vous même
comme si vous étiez l'observatrice de
vos propres sensations
les docteurs fleury est médecin
généraliste et possède un diplôme
universitaire d'hypnothérapie
tranquillité depuis quelques mois il
reçoit cette patiente qui souffre de
dépression de coco au cours de la séance
le médecin va s'assurer de son état
d'hypnose avec une lévitation du bras la
main se soulèvent d'elle-même sans que
la personne puisse agir vous sentez
cette man qui devient de plus en plus
légères de plus en plus légères on vous
sentez qu'elle pourrait se mettre à
flotter tout seul si c'est le cas voilà
vous l'a laissé faire voilà très bien
soyez juste attentive au plaisir à
l'agrément que ça vous procure françoise
il me manquait en médecine générale des
outils pour prendre en charge certains
problèmes de santé pour lesquelles la
médecine classique la chimiothérapie
comme on dit les médicaments peuvent pas
faire grand chose quand vous êtes bien
réveillé physiquement voilà vous ouvrez
les yeux
c'est dur alors à monter un ça va
voilà voilà
ouvrez les yeux laisser vous revenir
voilà vous sortez de votre bulle
très bien j'avais plus de solution pour
moi ça faisait trois ans que j'ai je
galérais g dans la maladie j'ai été
hospitalisée trois fois pas d'issue dès
la première séance j'ai su que mais
s'était passé quelque chose et j'ai su
que que je m'en sortirai c'est là que
j'ai compris que c'était énorme cité ou
avec une chose très intéressante je
crois que c'était la troisième séance où
elle m'a dit je me sens redevenir comme
j'étais avant
well as françois ce que j'étais à
goulens pc
[Musique]
l'état d'hypnose est un état modifié de
conscience différent du sommeil pour y
arriver
l'hypnotiseur utilise d'abord une
technique d'induction qui peut être
brève et autoritaire ou plus longue et
progressive
une première étape suivie d'une phase
d'approfondissement cet état
psychologique particulier permet de
modifier radicalement les perceptions
sensorielles et notamment celle de la
douleur au chu de tours on pratique
l'hypnose sédation une forme
d'anesthésiques qui combine l'hypnose
avec des analgésiques locaux c'est le
domaine d'eric fournier médecin
anesthésiste les pneus c'est quelque
chose qui peut rendre vos coûts de ces
risques
ça peut servir aussi bien dans deux
interventions programmées que dans des
interventions une chance pour pour
diminuer la panoplie patients les
techniques qui nous permettent de gérer
tout ça pour les prédispositions
denticules oui il faut être imaginatif
et fait un peu farfelue et puis il faut
mais l'humour pour faire le parce qu'en
fait il faut savoir rebondir rapidement
parce que se tourne anesthésie on
utilise des techniques de confusion vous
allez voir il ya des choses qui vont
vous paraître un petit peu farfelue
peut-être que je tire mais tout ça
s'inscrit dans une technique une
technique complètement a ordonné cécile
guerra est ici pour une ablation de la
parathyroïdes pour cette patiente qui a
déjà subi de nombreuses opérations sous
anesthésie générale
l'hypnose est une chance justement je
voudrais éviter la chimie puisque ça
fait trois ans que
mon corps subit beaucoup de choses donc
effectivement j'ai hâte en fait même de
voir comment comment je vais réagir
ce n'est jamais comme une anesthésie
générale le patient qui
nous dit à la consultation qui ne veut
rien voir rien sentir rien entendre il
n'est pas il peut pas être candidat
l'hypno sédation parce que lors d'une
intervention chirurgicale avec un
patient sous hypnose
si vous voulez la scène se joue à trois
personnes l'hypnotiseur le patient le
chirurgien lors d'une anesthésie
générale
la scène se joue à deux personnes
le l'anesthésiste et le chirurgien à
berlin il est 13 heures 18 l'ambassade
de france sur la pariser platz vient de
fermer avant que l'opération ne démarre
une vingtaine de minutes sont
nécessaires pour hypnotiser la patiente
c'est un outil extrêmement puissant qui
utilisent les ressources les ressources
personnelles du patient et donc ça lui
permet en fait de participer de façon
active à sa guérison inspiré respirer
le bleu les reflets argentés le corps
l'esprit l'esprit qui tourne autour du
corps pendant l'opération
on entend seulement la voix de
l'anesthésiste en interaction avec
l'inconscient de la patiente à 4
centimètres du corps elle va pas se
focaliser sur le geste opératoire sur
l'incision sur ses sensations qu'elle va
qu'elle va voir pendant l'intervention
et donc du coup bas pour nous c'est
beaucoup plus simple on va pouvoir
l'opérer dans de bonnes conditions sans
avoir la patiente qui sans arrêt va
diriger malou attention où se crisper
etc les yeux sont ouverts
pouvez-vous fermer l'oeil gauche en
gardant l'oeil droit ouvert on peut
entrer sortir d'hypnose c'est pas un
problème
les patients et moi il m'est arrivé que
des patients sorte d'hypnose me disent
que mon histoire les intéressent pas ou
qu'ils voulaient la date et l'endroit
qu'ils voulaient faire telle chose et
repartez et c'est reparti et en général
quand il replonge en hypnose il tombe
dans un stade plus profond ac les nerfs
encore un peu d'eau pas de pression
artérielle non fallait absolument que
j'ai toujours cette voix
la bible et je pense que justement
pendant l'intervention
je pensais dans cette voie et
je pense que j'aurais mal
elle suppose l'intervention le temps de
séjour est très réduit du coup donc ça
c'est surprenant parce que l'écart
minimum une demi heure voire une heure
voire plus donc là c'est très réduit en
fait on les garde fous même des fois
plus pour la surveillance chirurgie cap
et anesthésie donc ça ensuite c'est
surprenant de voir arriver il nous parle
comme si je n'avais pas été opérés
points et puis qui sont très très
satisfait avec sa manche à 17 sec de
l'hypnose c'est très positif a fait si
cette technique se développe les puces
je pense que la prise en charge globale
du patient serait meilleur et puis ça
pourrait remettre ça peut nous permettre
de remettre le patient au coeur du
système de santé actuellement lié plus
du tout
[Musique]
à
oh
l'hypnose thérapeutique
celle qui soigne suscite un réel
engouement le club d'hypnose d'orléans
organise régulièrement des stages dits
de coaching qui sont tous complets le
formateur et sylvain brossé un ancien
cadre dans l'informatique passé par
l'institut français d'hypnose
ericksonienne d'autres choses que vous
avez pratiqué pendant cette semaine
isabel sur ma fille elle avait une
journée un peu particulière il ya une
semaine mercredi et puis une personne
sur l'image de soi et puis une douleur
au niveau d'une sciatique
donc on a fait je pensais faire une
micro séance parce que l'on se connaît
bien et puis du coup je dis bavière on
va faire quelque chose assez rapide et
finalement ça a duré une heure donc on a
traité l'image de soi et puis à les
ressortir les pumas oui la belle il ya
des gens du club d'hypnose qui alors que
leurs enfants vont pas bien on veut
mener ont besoin d'un petit coup de
boost et c'est un petit coup d'hypnose
et ça s'apprend très vite il n'y a pas
de dons pour faire de l'hypnose c'est
juste une technique qui s'apprend et en
l'espace d'un trimestre s'avère déjà
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
les participants à ce stage ont tous des
motivations différentes mais un même
intérêt pour le développement personnel
moi ce que je découvre c'est que c'est
vraiment ça m'a donné confiance en moi
je suis quelqu'un extrêmement timide
dans la vie
la preuve si je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est un bel
exemple comme quoi on arrive à se
dépasser
quand quand on pratique au départ j'ai
senti qu'on pouvait aider les gens et
aider les gens a justement à avoir accès
c'est potentiel à réussir à développer
des choses en eux ou améliorer des
choses en lui c'est vrai qu'avec des
méthodes comme l'hypnose c'est des
thérapies assez bref qui permettent de
résoudre le problème assez rapidement
sans avoir forcément à identifier les
raisons un fouillis donc ça économise
l'argent ça économise le temps ça
économise les difficultés émotionnelles
que ça peut engager avec les prises de
conscience les larmes et c est en fait
on va régler le problème à la base sans
forcément savoir comment il se règle et
comment il se met en place
grâce à leur conscience mais ça marche
je crois ce que dit il devrait y avoir
des vrais sur recherche universitaire
approfondies je sais qu'il y en a un
petit peu aux états unis il y en a eu
beaucoup si pendant la guerre froide qui
était quand même assez assez secrète à
ses cachets mais il y aurait vraiment
beaucoup à faire au niveau
pharmaceutique et médical le problème
c'est que avec l'hypnose on sonne
tellement de choses sans prendre
produits chimiques que peut-être que ça
embêterait beaucoup les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et toute l'industrie qui
travaillent autour du mal être des gens
j'ai envie de dire puisque des bien-être
[Musique]
monde
à son bureau sylvain brossé reçoit aussi
des clients pour les mêmes indications
qu en cabinet médical
pascal est venu le consulter pour des
problèmes de confiance en elle
je doute toujours de ce que je peux
dégager par exemple par rapport aux
autres
l'image qui peuvent se faire de moi et
je suis pas sûr toujours d'avoir d'être
intéressante en fait et voilà c'est
quelque chose que tu te dis passe
quelque chose que tu ressembles que je
me dis d'accord
la personne qui vient me voir souvent
elle va pas bien elle a envie de changer
mais elle sait pas exactement ce qu'elle
voudrait
comment est ce qu elle veut changer et
je donne souvent cette cette métaphore
c'est comme si vous mettiez dans votre
voiture vous demandant votre gps vous
mettiez toutes les adresses où vous
voulez pas aller à un moment donné il
faut donner l'adresse où on veut aller
l'objectif de ce qu'on appelle un
endless cette partie de la séance au
début la séance est vraiment d'arriver à
déterminer l'objectif de la personne au
moulin - va toucher le visage parce
qu'elles tuent va ressentir quelque
chose d'intense fort et intense et de
très agréable à la fois un petit peu
comme si toutes ces sensations émergé
comme un feu d'artifice à l'intérieur de
toi
où je m'en vais à l'inconscient de faire
en sorte que ces sensations parce
qu'elles puissent faire sentir à chaque
fois qu'elle a une décision à prendre
chaque fois qu'elle est en relation avec
d'autres personnes à chaque fois que
avant elle avait une sensation de manque
de confiance
est-ce que l'inconscient peut mettre ce
nouveau comportement en place ok super
alors je demandais à l'inconscient de
faire ça maintenant et profondément et
de manière durable la force de l'hypnose
c'est que on va reprogrammer d'une
certaine manière des habitudes qui ont
été déléguées à l'inconscient donc en
fait à partir du moment où on
reprogramme des habitudes qui
sont néfastes négatif pour nous un petit
peu comme si vous programmez un
ordinateur qui auraient des bugs et bien
derrière ça vous permet de mieux être de
mieux vivre
donc c'est le côté thérapeutique de
l'ipo c'est que ben une phobie une
un trauma une addiction et ses cdd
programmation qui sont dans le cerveau
on reprogramme gentiment tranquillement
et derrière les gens vont mieux
j'avais l'impression de ne plus rien
d'être plus rien fait et c'est vraiment
un avant et un après une nouvelle vie
qui s'ouvraient à moi est vraiment
tourné sur le présent et le futur et
plus du tout dans le passé c'était
quelque chose d'extraordinaire et de
très surprenant parce qu en une séance
je suis passée de l'obscurité à grand
jour c'est un peu comme si avant j'étais
en train de noyer depuis longtemps je
j'arrivais à peine à sortir la tête hors
de l'eau et l'hypnose ça a été un peu
comme comme une main tendue qui m'a
sorti de là et et qui m'a permis
vraiment de revivre et de voir toute la
joie qu'il peut y avoir dans ma vie donc
vraiment vraiment passés de l'obscurité
à la grande clarté vraiment
[Musique]
pendant plus de deux siècles les
pratiques d'hypnos se sont heurtés au
scepticisme de la communauté médicale
si une partie d'entre elle admet
aujourd'hui que l'hypnose modifie bien
l'activité du cerveau le mystère demeure
encore sur les mécanismes qui rendent le
phénomène possible un immense défi à
relever pour les neurosciences dans la
compréhension du fonctionnement de
l'esprit